[Music]
forty-three seconds of logos also
illumination I am The Lorax I speak for
the trees stalk if you must on that
stage on our screen but narrations
narration whether seen or unseen
so does all the shrubbery have an air
delivery guy sensor if they're plastic
why wouldn't they just be up all the
time sings position
[Music]
okay your towns polluted why do you
sound so happy about it also who's this
player bowtie girl on each arm can you
have his own movie can we call him the
toy slur funny immature but exactly why
is this one need Ian frozen did the
giant white overalls cut off the
circulation to his nether region oh hi
Ted Ted might have the creepiest stalker
tactic in the history of film this is a
children's film I remind you considering
this building is taller than the
surrounding houses Ted should have been
able to see this from the front of
Audrey's house those are trees real ones
how does she know this and even if she
does she admits she's never seen one so
how is she able to paint them with this
much detailed accuracy had me smelled
like butterfly milk Wow
what does that even mean horny Ted would
be excellent at cinemasins
a guy somehow got you one well I
probably marry him on the spot I bet
that sounds crazy is that so crazy not
to future serial stalker possible killer
Ted I get this is supposed to be funny
but from a marketing standpoint it makes
zero sense why this company would put a
disco setting in their product over say
top 40s pop setting my disco also how
does the tree make the lights go off
inside the house if you're going to
leave this button unsecured and easy to
activate why install a stair mechanism
in the first place just build stairs or
I don't know a door at ground level
having the first stair located chest
level directly under the activation
button is not only the most dangerous
option but also to I off the ground to
be easily accessed the more smog in the
sky the more people will buy if O'Hare
is just coming to this realization I'm
having a hard time figuring out how he
made his zillions why is he leaving town
no one ever leaves then maybe you should
make it a little harder for the people
to get out maybe you have a passcode or
handprint sensor instead of just a big
button to open the door if the air this
close is so bad how does it not impact
neat Vil I didn't see any kind of dome
what separates the good air from the bat
how did he even find this place was
there only one road that led directly
here I don't know about trees what
happened wasn't keeping him on the hook
up by the window have been easier for
carrying on a conversation how could Ted
even hear him from down on the ground I
was a young man narrated story within a
narrated story welcome to near ception
if somehow your invention ends up a
failure instead of a success oh it
wouldn't surprise me at all mom Chloe
the magical self amplified electric
guitar is magical what kind of bad
compression are they using down in the
marshmallow factory to make this
marshmallow money shot happen oh yes
right after the musical number about the
kid who kept interrupting the story and
was never heard from again he just
threatened Ted with murder is this
setting up a horror sequel maybe a
collaboration between Seuss and Stephen
King can we call it needful things see
once-ler apparently has the strength of
10 men in that skinny hipster body
little did I know that by jumping down
that tree I had just summoned a mystical
creature as old as time itself
known as the beat you over the head with
an environmental message creature where
did Ted's insta house come from his cart
seems like more material than he would
have had but fine let's say it was in
his cart how did he build it so fast and
all by himself so you're telling me you
just didn't see me magically appear out
of that stump with all the lightning and
thunder and stuff see any of that The
Lorax has a good point
even if Ted didn't see him pop out of
the trunk he had to notice the lightning
and thunder along with the dark clouds
that randomly appeared and disappeared
if you want to hear more come back
tomorrow there is literally no reason
for Sir once-ler lot to delay finishing
this TED talk other than the movie wants
to movie a little bit more before he
finishes I know this is a dream sequence
and everything but how did she blow out
the candles on the other side of that
cake wow that's some expert level
daydreaming right there you're so into
it you're forgetting you're holding a
box of cereal with mom and grandma at
the table I'm not sure how this Susie
and Scrabble works with no points listed
on the tiles and a playing board that's
way too small but I do know that gramma
so just completely vanished into thin
air okay it was already obvious that
neat Ville has no building safety
standards but these skinny stairs
without a guardrail just gave me
secondhand vertigo and not the good
Jimmy Stewart kind so all O'Hare did was
tell Ted he shouldn't leave the town
again he didn't think to post guards at
the exit door or anything that would be
useful in deterring the situation not
sure why Ted is surprised here this is
exactly what happened the last time he
rang the doorbell why don't you like
other kids breakdancing him wearing
bell-bottoms and playing the Donkey Kong
stalky Kong does this mean this is in
our universe and not a fantasy world
I've been forgiving a lot of silliness
thinking this some other fantasy world
but if you know Donkey Kong you should
also understand aerodynamic vehicles
fish not being able to breathe or sing
out of water and trees having leaves and
not cotton candy
here's 10 retroactive sins for all those
times I like your nonsense go how nice
to see someone so undeterred by things
like reality oh there pot I mean kettle
maybe go
Lim thinkin he can find a tree for his
crush but speaking of reality how do you
even live here there's no vegetation no
source of clean water your entire
existence is undeterred by things like
reality Firefly fish food falsely
fashions fake fish light flashlights
let's look past the fact that the
once-ler had some kind of portable house
in the back of his carriage
how does he have electricity who taught
you guys how to steal a bag who taught
them what a bed was Mission Impossible
theme during a secret job cliche also
fishing impossible
these bar-ba-loots going all Fisher
friends not food certainly makes sense
in a kids movie but we all know that
these discount Bears would have devoured
every one of these harmonious halibuts
in the real world right I know there's
some wood on that bed frame but I'm
still guessing the iron frame and
overall weight make this buoyant bedtime
business a bust now you're concerned for
his life if baby bar balut hadn't been
on that bed he probably would have just
gone chasing waterfalls without you and
died anyway the second you send a
sleeping man down a river you should
have already made your peace with him
sleeping where the humming fishes huh
the once-ler is suddenly dry even though
he was submerged in the river less than
a minute ago no a movie you do not have
my permission to continue to use these
creepy fin legged chipmunk sounding
human tooth having fish is a constant
sound effects machine enough is enough
apparently this fridge is powered by the
same magic electricity as Ted's guitar
but FFL but wait there's more thanks to
its all-natural microfibers the feed is
super absorbent it also works that so
it's a towel then you could have just
said it's a towel tomatoes are not water
balloons so let's say the knee did take
off in popularity how exactly did this
town have Improv Everywhere wannabes
find Ted in the middle of the forest
[Music]
actually no but I think he's gonna get
to that part really soon yes that's
right he got sent home it's story again
just so the movie could remind us how
battle here is how cute the girlfriend
is and how cool his grandma is we get it
Columbo is reading The Wonder Years Kato
book just get back to Wesley and
Buttercup already oh you know me just
Cruise and putting out the vibe the
creepy vibe this works go whoa Britt's
actually got a superhuman arm if need
bill had a pro team he could lead them
to the AFC Championship so they could
blow a lead to the Patriots why did the
once-ler think inviting his super
annoying and unsupportive family on here
would help this RV breaks the first law
of thermodynamics so bad it makes Ted's
house from a cart seem almost plausible
also wow is there laundry that already
needs drying this isn't some rinky-dink
operation anymore I got plans big plans
because one person warrior invention is
a hat a tree falls the way it leans be
careful which way you lean yeah well a
strong carries liquid the way you suck
so be careful how hard you suck see we
can do it too well what else can we do
we could always start chopping down the
trees but wouldn't harvesting the Tufts
be the better action in the long run if
the trees cut down it can't grow any
more this is bad is about as deep as
this movie wants to go and exploring its
environmental message maybe I'm
expecting too much from a kids movie but
even the dr. Seuss book it was based on
is more nuance than this and it even had
to rhyme and everything this may be the
worst song I've ever heard one of these
kid flicks seriously this makes
VeggieTales feel like Handel's Messiah
in comparison what an absolute piece of
Barbra Lutz cat
the animal that doesn't want self
someone else's so this is essentially
the circle of life made simpler one
could say the Lorax is just The Lion
King for dummies this could just as
easily be the slogan for illumination
studios oh come on newbie there's no way
this character got this greedy and this
evil this quick screw you a movie right
and you're smooth you know that strange
secret hole in your groovy loose club
the very last one that may stop you you
know my problem with the story is that
he isn't so much undone by his greed
he's actually undone by his complete
ignorance of basic botany I wonder so
younger O'Hara looks exactly like O'Hara
except with braces our bracelets now
shorthand for doom Butte sold over 52
million of these things and he should
have made some profits the last truffula
seed you need to plant it Ted you have a
seed this whole time where did you get
it
why couldn't you use it why on Zeus is
green Gribble grass did you not try and
plant it when you were in full
megalomaniac mode why is he just
disabling this surveillance catnap he's
been to see the once-ler three times now
come to think of it as big a deal as
this movie made over O'Hara's
voyeuristic tendencies how did he sneak
out so easily twice more after being
warned setting aside that this destroyed
camera somehow still has power if I'm
reading this boot-up string right that
looks like he's trying to reboot and
keeps getting errors and therefore
should not be functioning near enough to
grab this information the scene had a
few drops of water spilled on it and
seconds later is already sprouting even
beyond the premature tree germination
how would a tree that reproduces this
quickly even be in danger of extinction
I'm sure just go sue here is happy the
decoy worked but has she forgotten she's
close to toppling off this ledge exit
vehicle first laughs later you know when
your life is no longer at risk safe to
guess the Ted's mom with the opposite
direction is these three to lead this
truck away as a decoy so how exactly are
they now crossing paths and if Ted's mom
didn't go the opposite direction just
consider this a sin for her stupidity
Wow geez granny you just bone owed that
dude have a little compassion nice to
see they let Zack Snyder director seen
we don't why you're really against trees
because they produce fresh air it's
called photosynthesis how does she know
this who taught her about photosynthesis
in a world without trees but exactly how
I'm having a hard time grasping the
geography here aren't we just in the
town centre and did he have to drive up
a huge hill to hit the wall also how is
he even knocking down the wall here when
he left need bill the first time it
didn't look like the sign had any road
below it also he drove around inside the
wall it's Hollow and at least 30 feet
wide he may punch a hole but he ain't
taking it down also also that is either
and muddy strong bulldozer or that is
one weak-ass wall my guess is that
O'Hare built the wall but had the Barbra
Lutz pay for it you get out there right
now and get these people on my side or
else you're fired everyone clearly would
hurt that so not sure how hair is
helping us cause you can't breathe blood
you don't so is it just me or did
someone forget to make these guys why
are their lips moving but I'm still just
hearing TED news mom Thank You Ted does
that mustache give the once-ler super
sight how does he have any idea what's
happening from this distance this might
have gotten fixed a whole lot sooner if
the Lorax hadn't left a one-word obscure
clue also end of movie reading your
feature-length film barely reached
minute 80 with nothing substantial
important or weighty it's so short you
exclaim should we add something more
dear god no says the crowd let us head
to the door yet you added the end screen
and crush all our wishes with 20 full
seconds of these damn dancing fishes
that's not right
[Music]
those are trees real ones they're real
they're spectacular
[Music]
for shame shame and some flapjacks too
early for flapjacks I'll take care if I
had a dick this is where I'd tell you
the suck